you sent me a great essay from from Paul
Graham I'm a big fan of that I think it
explains a lot of your success the essay
is called how to do great work and
people should go definitely read the
full essay there's a few things I could
read from it uh some quotes having new
ideas is a strange game because it
usually consists of seeing things that
were right under your nose once you've
seen a new idea it tends to seem obvious
Why did no one think of this before
seeing something obvious sounds easy and
yet empirically having new ideas is hard
and like the steps you took seem trivial
and yet nobody was taking them or at
least in the past they weren't
successful so the successes you've had
were as simple as essentially picking up
the phone or trying mhm um there's a lot
of interesting things here to talk about
this aspect of doing the seemingly
simple that seems to be so hard to to do
uh it as Paul describes requires a
willingness to break rules there are two
ways to be comfortable breaking rules to
enjoy breaking them and to be
indifferent to them that's an
interesting distinction I call these two
cases being aggressively and passively
independent minded so again that's to
enjoy breaking the rules or be
indifferent to the rules uh the
aggressively independent minded are the
naughty ones rules don't merely fail to
stop them breaking rules gives them
additional energy for this sort of
person delight at the sheer of audacity
of a project sometimes supplies enough
activation energy to get it started the
other way to break the rules is not to
care about them at all or perhaps even
to know they exist this is why novices
and Outsiders often make new discoveries
their ignorance of a field ignorance
maybe in quotes of a Field's assumptions
act as a source of temporary pass of
independent mindedness aspies also seem
to have a kind of immunity to
Conventional beliefs several I know say
that this helps them to have new ideas
so the aggressive and the passive is
such an interesting way of looking at it
um perhaps some aspect of this at least
in the story you tell is some passive
aspect where you're like not
even acknowledging not even caring that
there was rules just kind of asking the
simple question and taking the simple
action I think that it's myny that was
an essay I read and we're doing just a
snippet of it but I would encourage
anyone listening to go and find it and
read the entire thing because it's
something that really spoke to me as I
was transitioning uh into my new career
now and I just loved it but when we were
talking about uh why certain people who
don't have traditional qualifications
are able to come in and do incredible
work and solve complex problems it made
me think of that essay which is why I
shared it and I I think that in the
context of the work that I was doing
here uh perhaps not having
the historical context uh became an
advantage and obviously went back and
then tried to study it but you if you go
into a problem I always find that
especially in the political realm my
favorite um political issues are ones
where they're contrarian by being
obvious and you know sometimes they feel
very intuitive and so you take them on
there's always a lot of resistance when
you go against something that's been
accepted um as the way that you're
supposed to do things um and I came to
learn over the course of my time in
government that when everyone was
agreeing with what I was doing then it
actually made me more nervous because I
felt like you have these problems they
haven't been solved for a long time and
then if you take the same approach as
others you're going to fail just like
they did so taking a different approach
doesn't mean you're going to succeed but
at least if you fail you're going to
fail in an original way and so I did
like this a lot and I I think that um
you know what I saw was the people who
were very good at getting things done
that hadn't been done before were people
who came with different qualifications
different perspectives and they came in
and and really work the problem in
untraditional ways and so I think in the
Middle East I came in with a very
different approach than people before me
not because I came in deliberately
trying to do it differently but because
I came in trying to listen and
understand from people why the problem
hadn't been solved and then think from a
first principal's perspective on what's
the right perspective today not based on
what happened 50 years ago or not based
on what somebody's feelings who were
hurt but what's the right thing to make
people's lives better to make the world
uh a safer and and and more prosperous
place
tomorrow